alright boys we got one relationship
advice for me one we're really helping
the nation with this stuff you do yeah I
remember the last dude who was smoking
weed with his wife I came we gave him
just dimes what is this relationship
with us let's get cat why don't you help
us house start off you what is it don't
play the video well I just want a female
perspective I'm tired of listening to
this a real female perspective I'm time
to listen to this big [ __ ] over here
Punk it's his relationship advice on
snapchat
yeah well I cut it I already eliminated
it from my phone all right boys first we
got Lindsay Miller this is Lindsay
Miller asking for some relationship this
decayed a girl got that lens craft case
this is Lindsay out of Illinois I had a
relationship question for you I've been
dating this guy for about six years now
and we just separated about a week and a
half ago long story short he has issues
with financial stability which I take
personally with bad attitude I'm not the
friendliest person in the world but we
do love each other dearly we believe
that we're soul mates we don't want to
be with anybody else but we just can't
seem to get along because he's broke in
a bad mood all the time because we do
love each other so much that we should
just let it be that and be together or
if each of our issues we should take
seriously and may be soul mates just
because her so much doesn't mean that
we're meant to be together
you know sometimes stuff doesn't work
out so I want to know your opinion on it
and thanks for listening Gang Gang buzz
buzz buzz buzz girl like the purple nail
polish I love Illinois Maine one of my
favorite places in the whole world
I like Illinois Australia I think yeah
you might want to just take some time
apart and figure out maybe what's going
on on your own in I think a little time
apart could give you probably some
perspective you know it's nothing for
myself I find when I'm in a relationship
I'm in a close-knit proximity with
someone sometimes I get so I can't even
see what's going on because I'm just in
there it's like
don't know what's going on outside the
box yeah it's a camera from said a damn
forum said it if I'm upset at me like I
don't really know where my issues are so
I think taking some time apart to
probably be good and look these days if
you have somebody that's a best friend
like you could make a relationship out
of that like not being a cheap ass box
here's what's going on with her
sounds like dipping in for six years
homeboys never found a job so she's
frustrated with it hmm you tell me
homeboy hasn't found a job in six years
maybe just lazy maybe that's why you're
frustrated yeah maybe he's a punk well I
mean yeah one yeah you can't be the only
breadwinner cuz you're gonna probably
end up having some resentments against
it or maybe wants to be a sugar baby I
mean some people will be show your
babies tell me if you don't think it's
just women won't be sugar babies dudes
like to be sugar baby pause oh yeah
that's true they got them baby sugar
baby punk so maybe if you could start a
small business give him a job dude
start driving uber yeah has he tried
that well there's probably some
opportunity out there for him but yeah
if you're angry obviously if you're
upset something either you're upset at
him or something just not making you
happy but I'd figure out what that is
especially for your soul mates money
doesn't break up soul mates you know I'm
saying well she says that they still
want to be soul mates Brendan yeah it
looks like you're looking for an
expensive soul mate you feel me
well I mean you can't have a soul mate
that's just eaten all the snacks and
doing all of the cheese slices by
themselves and you don't have anything
left yeah you got split up them
dunkaroos baby yeah you need a snack
mate you need somebody to contribute to
a snack pool yep get them gushers get
the fruit by the foot yeah bye good luck
maybe just take a little bit of space
and figure it out step outside the box
you have the cheap-ass bugs but you got
to accept him too if he doesn't want to
get a job and you're still and you're
gonna be with him then don't hold it
against him every day that he doesn't
have a job yeah if he wants to be lazy
Larry LEM do his thing you signed up for
it right yeah you just have to like at
some point it's not fair for you to be
like you don't have a job every day then
you're just having him stay around so
you could be be kind of rude maybe -
yeah if you come home from your 9:00 to
5:00 and he's making forts every day he
playing [ __ ] call of duty be cool
that's what you signed up for
teddy grahams that sounds like the live
no thank you laughs Lazar this guy's
awesome be cool lady yeah [ __ ] cool
what else you got
well let's go to the let's go over to
the let's get order an actual female
Brendan not this you know an actual
female
I mean after six years I think she's
just mad that he isn't contributing I
think he doesn't have a job or he
doesn't have a higher paying job he's
lazy Larry exactly but after six years
you got to know whether you want to be
with that for for the next like 20 30
years or if you need to find someone
else me a soul mate is great but then
the day you're gonna resent them if they
don't pull their share but what did tell
you if your soul mates lazy as [ __ ]
what's it say if your soul mates Oscar
the Grouch but also you can't just be
mean to him every day maybe does she get
off on that because some girl I feel
like some people a sensation but some
people do like to have like a punching
bag to come home to regardless of what
he's trying to do cuz I mean maybe he's
trying his very best she's not who she's
smoking cigarettes playing call duty
late at night yeah well maybe I'd open
up snapchat looking at booty hauls maybe
that's why she's an [ __ ] yeah well
maybe they still live in an apartment
okay and they don't live in a fancy
house that as a pool and extra sinks
well maybe they should get their [ __ ]
together cuz they can yeah maybe they
can't you delinquent you a punk
Wow mean guy well okay [ __ ] is quit
being mean can we go to the coast
applications again for a nice person see
if anybody put that on their application
not this DV and who said he went to
college nobody's ever heard of it
Manchester State wouldn't the [ __ ] was
that man what Jesus Christ man
what it sounds like you and her should
get together oh yeah oh yeah okay get a
job you bandwagon fan is not a job dude
your fan doesn't pay the bills
yeah they build forts and eat [ __ ]
Teddy Grahams every afternoon what's
that your Zion Williams cinders II just
came in oh wow and it's tight
yep at yours it's a medium ha alright
let's get to the end of this dude I
can't stay I can't deal with them
anymore I avoid broccolini